日本語の音声学には、-3
ルールとして知られる非常に高度な非常に複雑なルール
があり
ます。これは、将来のレッスンでこのルールを詳細に分解しますが
、ルールの本質は
、名詞内でダウンステップが発生すると、3番目に発生する傾向があるということです。
村
最後から
ランダムな文字を組み合わせ
て偽の単語を作ると、東京の話者は
、モデルの崩壊と同じように、最後から3番目のダウンステップで発音します。
これは
同じ現象です。 これは、
英語のネイティブスピーカーが日本語の単語
を見て特定の方法で発音するときに発生します。たとえば
、大阪や横浜ではなく、大阪
や横浜のように、
私たち全員が
無意識のうちに再生する音声規則があります。日本語で
は、これらの規則の1つがマイナス3の
規則です。 名詞でダウンステップが発生するのは
、最後から3番目に多く発生
する傾向があり、カタカナのローンワード
の大部分はこのマイナス3の
役割に準拠しているため、ランダムなloaのクラスターを使用すると
このような単語で
は、ほとんどの
場合、単語の終わりから3番目の村でダウンステップが発生することがわかります。
これ
は、アクセントが元の単語とは異なる場所にある場合でも当てはまります。
英語のバナナ
とキーボードのアクセントはこことここにあり
ますが、日本の現象と
キーボードでは、すべてのダウンステップがここと
ここにあります単語の3モーフ平均
カタカナ外来語の大部分
は、ダウンステップ3でより頻繁に終わりと言われます
言葉のそしてこれは私たち
を特別なサウンドルールに戻します